[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec vos petits bonhommes
ont gentiment bonjour orium est notre
invité cette semaine et valérie rabault
bonjour vous êtes député socialiste de
tarn-et-garonne et vous êtes présidente
du groupe nouvelle gauche à l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec merci à vous
et cette semaine l'actualité
parlementaire a d'abord été marquée par
l'examen de la loi ferroviaire au sénat
alors que la grève se poursuit à la sncf
le gouvernement a profité des débats
pour amender sa copie après les
dernières concertation syndicale
les sénateurs ont aussi pratiqué
plusieurs retouches les organisations
réformistes seront elles satisfaites de
cette version du texte il sera en tout
cas voter à mardi prochain à l'assemblée
la semaine a été marquée par l'adoption
de la loi agriculture et alimentation le
texte comporte des avancées en ce qui
concerne notamment les revenus des
agriculteurs
sa timidité sur les questions
écologiques et sur la défense du
bien-être animal a en revanche été
déplorés sur de nombreux bancs enfin
mastodonte législatif 65 arctique plus
de trois mille amendements la loi élan
sur le logement est débattu depuis
mercredi dans l'hémicycle à l'assemblée
elle vise notamment à accélérer la
construction mais plusieurs points
suscitent l'inquiétude notamment la
nouvelle gestion et la vente des
logements sociaux
et on commence cette semaine avec la
réforme ferroviaire examiné au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rassurer les syndicats réformistes aient
tenté de mettre fin à la grève c'était
l'enjeu du passage du texte devant le
sénat les sénateurs ont renforcé les
garanties sociales pour les salariés et
défendu l'aménagement du territoire avec
l'appui du gouvernement
fabien becker très mobilisés les
sénateurs communistes n'auront pas
déjouer les plans du gouvernement le
sénat a adopté la fin du recrutement des
cheminots aux statuts dès 2020 une
mesure attendue par les français pour le
rapporteur du texte
sa comparaison entre cheminots et
parlementaire a fait bondir le groupe
communiste c'est la réalité des dés de
la perception des français
il pense que les parlementaires sont des
privilégiés il pense que les cheminots
sont deux des privilégiés j'ai mal je
crois qu'on peut pas prendre cet
argument là c'est quoi le les privilèges
réel des cheminots et des cheminotes
dans ce pays
il rapporte les sénateurs ont également
voté la transformation de la sncf
d'établissement public en société
anonyme à capitaux publics pour le
groupe communiste le gouvernement avance
masqué ce changement de statuts ouvrant
la voie à la privatisation
il ya déjà eu des expériences dans notre
pays on avait ce qui pour privatiser
ensuite pour rassurer les cheminots les
sénateurs ont inscrit dans le texte
l'incessibilité des capitaux publics de
la sncf et de ses filiales
la ministre des transports a tenté
d'éteindre une fois pour toutes
la petite musique d'une privatisation de
la sncf je pense qu'il est bien pour la
qualité des débats et pour la bonne
compréhension des cheminots qu'il soit
dit une fois pour toutes que la sncf et
public restera public était inscrit dans
la loi pour insensible au sénat la
défense des territoires et des petites
lignes a occupé une large partie des
débats contre l'avis du gouvernement les
sénateurs ont adopté un amendement censé
protéger des régions contre
d'éventuelles hausse des péages
ferroviaires
malgré un beau le sénat donc modifier le
texte souvent avec l'appui du
gouvernement pour renforcer le volet
social garantir et l'incessibilité de
l'entreprise c'est à dire pas de
privatisation est ce que vous êtes
rassurés ce reportage montre deux
amendements que nous avions porté et que
la ministre
balayé d'un revers de main le premier
concerné l'incessibilité je suis ravi
qu'elle ait donné un avis favorable
comme quoi on peut changer d'avis elle
change beaucoup d'avis mais dont ça
c'est important c'est à dire de dire
qu'il faut effectivement que la sncf ne
les y étions pas favorable à sa
transformation en société anonyme
le gouvernement souhaite le faire mais à
minima qu'on mette un garde-fou et qui
s'appelle 7 incessibilité pour qu'on
puisse garder la sncf public
le deuxième volet on avait eu un très
long débat avec la ministre pareil à
nous expliquer que non que nous posions
des questions qui n'avait pas lieu
d'être que ce que nous disions été faut
porter sur la question des péages
si vous voulez tuer une ligne qu'est ce
que vous faites vous mettez un ph très
élevé et là vous dites c'est dommage il
ya aucune société qui veut venir
l'exploiter c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer donc que nous nous avions demandé
que les péages soient plafonnées c'est à
dire que on ne puisse pas avoir une
inflation qui bloque une société pour
venir exploiter la ligne
elle avait refusé je vois que nos amis
sénateurs ont obtenu gain de cause c'est
effectivement deux avancées très
important qui est aussi des avancées sur
ce qu'on appelle le saccage social est
ce que là dessus le compte y est et est
ce que vous appelez du coup les
organisations syndicales y compris
réformiste à poursuivre ou prolonger la
grève ou à l'arrêter mais alors il ya
des avancées pour effectivement dire si
un agent de la sncf est transférée à une
société qui exploite une ligne il faut
qu'ils puissent au pouvoir revenir
nous ce que nous avions demandé en plus
lors du débat avec un amendement que
nous avions déposé c'est de dire qu'il
faut comprendre en compte l'ancienneté
quand vous partez si vous êtes
transférer la sncf à une nouvelle
société qui va exploiter la ligne
il faut que vos années d'ancienneté à la
sncf puisse être inscrite dans votre
nouveau contrat dans la société qui va
exploiter la ligne
la ministre l'avait refusé je pense tout
ça c'est très important ça se fait dans
d'autres cadres il n'y a pas de raison
que ça se lasse pas progressé sur le
mouvement social est ce qu'il est encore
justifié après cet examen au sénat et le
vote de mardi
il ya il y avait trois questions qui
étaient posées la reprise de la dette il
ya eu des avancées par contre sur le
statut social des cheminots dont la
ministre a quand même dit qu'il sera
responsable du niveau de dette de la
sncf il faut quand même se rappeler ce
qui a été dit à l'assemblée nationale
sur ce point là il ya un an
encore des incertitudes et troisième
volet qui concerne les petites lignes
leur exploitation il ya certes des
avancées au sénat avec les péages
mais sur ce point là nous avons quand
même de grandes inquiétudes notamment au
regard de ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres pays qui ont ouvert leurs
réseaux leur ligne à la concurrence
l'exploitation de la ligne à la
concurrence donc les cheminots doivent
continuer de se faire entendre
mais les cheminots doivent poursuivre
les négociations puisque je rappelle que
le gouvernement ne l'avait pas engagé
mais il était dit qu'il fallait qu'une
convention collective qu'ils soient
négociés
il faut aller jusqu'au bout de cette
négociation notamment sur la reprise de
l'ancienneté des agents de la sncf quand
ils sont transférés à la société qui
exploite la ligne parce que le texte tel
qu'il est sorti des débats du sénat
aujourd'hui le vous convient mais nous
nous n'étions pas nous ne sommes pas
favorables à des transformations société
anonyme à chaque fois que ça se passe
chaque fois à chaque fois vous avez des
promesses dans l'hémicycle et trois ans
après vous avez une ouverture du capital
au privé
donc ça c'est un point dur de cette
négociation
encore une fois les madame la ministre
isabel bornes dans quatre ans il ya peu
de chance qu'elle soit encore ministe et
transporte donc sa parole vaut
aujourd'hui mais ses successeurs
elle leur donne les ce qu'elle fait
c'est qu'elle rend la sncf privatisable
elle ne la privatise pas ça c'est vrai
elle la rend privatisable justement
elisabeth bourdin qui a défendu ce texte
elle a été directrice de la stratégie de
la sncf pendant cinq ans et ce qu'elle a
une responsabilité dans la situation
actuelle de l'entreprise selon vous mais
à chaque fois qu on est dirigeant d'une
entreprise on a nécessairement une
responsabilité sur la ligne conduit de
crise qu'on mais sans faire de jeu de
mots qu'on met sur une société qu'on
dirige donc oui elle a une
responsabilité le problème c'est qu'elle
souffre d'une forme d'amnésie à ses
chroniques puisque elle a oublié tout ce
qu'elle avait fait lorsqu'elle était à
la tête de cette société
allez on en vient notre deuxième thème
la loi agriculture et alimentation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un texte qui avait suscité
beaucoup d'espoir qui laisse pas mal de
monde sur sa faim la loi agriculture et
alimentation ont été adoptées mercredi à
l'assemblée après une semaine de débats
le ministre de l'agriculture stéphane
travert a jugé le texte équilibré
d'autres ont surtout relevé ces
manquements sur la question des
glyphosate notamment le résumé est
signée françois goulard glyphosate bio
dans les cantines doggy bag et abattoirs
le projet de loi et galim balaye
largement le sujet de l'alimentation et
de l'agriculture et des l'article 1er
les crispations ont été nombreuses sur
le coeur du texte
le revenu des agriculteurs avec cette
nouvelle loi les coûts de production
deviennent la base pour fixer les prix
des produits agricoles
le contrat et les prix associées seront
désormais proposés par celui qui vend
clause de renégociation plus
opérationnels pour faciliter la
réouverture des négociations
commerciales en cas d'évolution des
coûts de production lutte contre les
prix abusivement bas
encadrement des promotions seuil de
revente à perte fixé à 10%
mais au fur et à mesure des débats de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour dénoncer
un texte qui manque d'ambition votre
texte s'applique évidemment qu'en france
or nous sommes dans un marché dit
complètement ouvert le marché unique
européen
qu'est ce qui empêchera demain un
transformateur une grande surface qui
voudrait échapper l'application votre
texte d'aller acheter ses produits dans
un autre pays auprès d'agriculteurs qui
ne sont pas les agriculteurs français
c'est là la faille principale
autre déception des députés de
l'opposition la vidéo surveillance
obligatoire dans les abattoirs n'est pas
retenue pas plus que la création d'un
fonds pour les victimes des pesticides
mais c'est sur le glyphosate que les
échanges se sont tendus lundi soir son
interdiction d'ici 2021
pourtant une promesse d' emmanuel macron
n'est pas inscrite dans la loi
quand un produit est notoirement
dangereux il doit être interdit
le glyphosate est cancérogène probable
il doit être interdit et à elle seule la
sphère des monsanto peppers qui est la
plus grande falsification scientifiques
de l'histoire doit justifier notre
décision
contre plusieurs députés de sa propre
majorité
l'engagement du président la république
doit être tenu le rapporteur du texte en
terrain miné justifie son refus j'ai
complètement confiance en la parole du
président de la république j'ai pas
besoin d'inclure dans la loi pour être
assuré que cet engagement sera tenu
le gouvernement lui mettant en avant les
autres avancées de la loi 20% de bio
dans les cantines scolaires la mise en
place progressive des doggy bag dans les
restaurants ou encore la lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire
valérie rabault quel bilan tirez-vous
des débats sur cette loi on a vu dans la
presse de nombreux papiers déplorant les
reculades sur l'interdiction du
glyphosate sur l'étiquetage nutritionnel
sur la vidéosurveillance dans les
abattoirs et le rôle des lobbys a
largement été mise en cause
est-ce que vous attribuez aussi ses
manquements au poids des lobbys
constatés sur ce texte il ya beaucoup de
choses lors du débat moi je retiendrai
trois choses d'abord la première sur le
prix parce qu'on parle quand même de
l'agriculture c'est à dire que le à du
revenu qui est donné aux agriculteurs il
ya eu des avancées c'est à dire que la
loi sapin de avait déjà crantée pas mal
de choses il ya eu quelques petites
avancées dans ce texte il faut le
reconnaître mais il faut pas mentir aux
agriculteurs si votre cou coûts de
production par exemple est de 60 et que
un acheteur vous propose de vous payer
que 50 mais ça se fera donc vous vendrez
en dessous de votre coût de production
ça la loi ne le traite pas deuxième
sujet ce le débat a appuyé le texte de
loi qui a qui a été finalement votée et
13 ans de sa très en-deça des et auch
des états généraux de l'agriculture qui
nous avait donné une grande leçon je les
trouve être je les ai trouvés très
professionnelle avec des idées avec une
perspective avec une vision pour ce que
doit être l'agriculture française dans
cinq dix vingt ans de tout ça on n'a
rien retrouvé ni dans le débat ni dans
le texte donc ça pose un vrai sujet
troisième volet il ya un volet
environnemental bien entendu donc vous
avez parlé du glyphosate
moi je constate que pour notre groupe il
ya eu un amendement qui avait été
proposé par matthieu orphelin qui est
pas de notre groupe qui appartient au
groupe de la république en marche
cet amendement proche de nicolas hulot
peut-être
rien mes proches de nicolas hulot qui
était assez équilibré qui dit dans le
fond on interdit pendant trois ans et on
se met des dérogations jusqu'à cinq ans
parce qu'effectivement il faut encore
une fois comme dans toute industrie ou
production il faut prendre le temps mais
il faut toujours fixé un cap
là le texte ne fixe pas de cap
contrairement à ce qu'a dit le président
de la république cet amendement je le
répète il émanait de la république en
marche c'était pacino donc il a été voté
par notre groupe on avions soutenu
mais encore une fois il ne se retrouve
pas du tout dans le texte donc ce qui
j'ai l'impression est un peu la marque
de fabrique depuis quelques temps des
textes du gouvernement c'est qu'on fait
des annonces ambitieuse et ce qui est
voté c'est très très en-deça des
annonces qui ont été faites sur ce texte
n'est pas aussi le reflet des
tiraillements au sein de la majorité et
du gouvernement sur ces questions
environnementales sans doute mais ça
c'est à eux de le régler c'est a eu le
régler et pas de faire des lois qui sont
en deçà des annonces encore une fois la
grandeur de la politique c'est en
général de faire se rencontrer ce qu'on
dit et ce qu'on fait là ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya de plus en plus on voit
un fossé un décalage qui se crée entre
d'un côté les annonces et de l'autre ce
qui est réellement voté dans les textes
de loi
on en vient notre troisième thème la loi
logement
[Musique]
c'est un autre texte fleuve examiné
cette semaine à l'assemblée le projet de
loi logement un des dix fils complexe
qui vise notamment à accélérer la
construction dans le pays notamment
simplifiant un certain nombre de normes
mais le texte pourrait toucher à des
points sensibles comme la loi littoral
la gestion du parc hlm où la loi sru
explications félix ul 3400 amendement un
record depuis le début de la législature
je dirais que la première
caractéristique par rapport à toutes les
lois précédentes c'est que ce texte
n'ajoute pas de noms supplémentaires de
contraintes supplémentaires et que
c'était pour nous un objectif
fondamental que le simplifier cela passe
notamment par des dérogations à la loi
sru
afin de faciliter la transformation de
bureaux en logements
l'assouplissement de la loi littoral les
délais de recours contre un permis de
construire vont être raccourcies et
l'installation d'antennes relais sera
facilité à droite on dénonce un passage
en force la force est de constater que
le texte ne tient compte qu'à la marge
des alertes de nombreuses parties
prenantes comme l'association des maires
ou l'ordre des architectes
peut-on bâtir une politique efficace
sans eux l'aménagement équitable du
territoire exige de n'exclure personne
de n'oublier personne un secteur est
particulièrement impacté les hlm les
bailleurs sociaux dans le patrimoine
compte moins de 15000 habitants devront
fusionner et la vente de logements
sociaux sera facilité une mesure
dénoncée par la gauche
que va-t-il se passer dans les beaux
quartiers
là où il ya quelques logements sociaux
il ya où il ya des belles affaires à
faire des promoteurs privés vont arriver
vous racheter le logement social soit
les garder en les mettant en location
soit quelques années après les revendre
en vain une magnifique plus value et
dans les quartiers sociaux les plus
défavorisés là où il ya les produits les
moins attractifs ce sont des sociétés
privées qui sont soit directement des
marchands de sommeil soit des gens qui
vont acheter ou vendre à la découpe à
des marchands de sommeil qui eux
exploitent la misère humaine
l'article 18 sera aussi particulièrement
discuté aujourd'hui 100 % des logements
neuf doivent être accessibles aux
handicapés le projet de loi prévoit de
faire tomber ce taux à 10 %
valérie rabault mercredi dernier dans
une conférence de presse vous avez
estimé que ce projet doit l'en était je
cite le pire texte depuis le début du
quinquennat
pourquoi oui alors pourquoi on partage
l'objectif de construction de logements
ce qu'on regrette parce qu'on rate c'est
plus qu'on arrête ces on le déplore
c'est le fait que ce texte est tombé
beaucoup de garde-fous ce soit à la fois
en terme de mixité c'est à dire qu'il va
renforcer la ghettoïsation dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville est à
la fois en termes de protection du
patrimoine des français
gore une fois les logements sociaux les
hlm sont payés avec votre argent votre
argent du livret a que qui est déposé à
la caisse des dépôts et consignations et
donc quand on fait de la vente par bloc
on doit faire en sorte de vendre au
juste prix là le gouvernement fait
sauter ce qu'on appelle l'estimation du
prix par l'état
donc il ya un près libre vous pouvez les
vendre au prix que vous voulez y compris
le brader alors que ça a été payée avec
l'argent des français et deuxième volet
ça permet si des fonds de pension
américain vient de racheter les baux hlm
pour eux de faire des plus values
importantes sur le dos des français
donc ça ce sont deux points qui nous
inquiète énormément troisième point vous
l'avez dit dans votre petit reportage
si avec ce texte si vous voulez
installer une énorme antennes relais
devant le château de versailles et bien
maintenant ce sera possible
est-ce alors qu'aujourd'hui en france on
fait quand même attention à ce qu'ils
aient une protection de notre paysage ça
se soit trois exemples qui montrent que
les garde-fous sont en train d'être levé
avec ce texte
et là évidemment là dessus nous ne
sommes pas d'accord est ce que vous
craignez un assouplissement de la loi
sru qui impose aux communes un quota de
logements sociaux alors le gouvernement
a dit qu'il ne faisait pas nous on pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin attendre
député de la république en marche
oui entendre cette petite musique je
pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient nous on
vous l'avait cité contre-projet que nous
avons présentées que françois pupponi
qui est notre chef de file a présenté
mercredi dernier c'est de dire il faut
créer une forme de continuum de mixité
avoir du logement très social social et
de l'intermédiaire nous nous proposons
que ces trois catégories logements soit
désormais intégré dans le comptage qui
vaut pour la loi sru avec une
pondération un logement très social
il compterait pour un 5 1 logement
intermédiaire et compterait pour 0,5 ce
qui vous fait une forme de ponte de
continuité dans l'accession et dans les
quêtes les différentes natures de
logements qui peuvent être proposées
c'est ça la mixité c'est pas de mettre
toutes les populations qui ont des
difficultés au même endroit comme ce que
c'est un peu la tendance que prend le
texte hélas nous ne sommes pas du tout
d'accord c'est pour ça que je dis qu'en
disait que c'était le pire texte nous
nous sommes très attachés à la cohésion
de la société
le logement est un levier majeur pour
assurer cette cohésion de la société
mais pas par avec ce qui est proposé
dans ce texte on va terminer cette
semaine avec une polémique déclenchée
par gérard collomb c'était mercredi lors
d'une audition au sénat le ministre de
l'intérieur est venu présenter le projet
doazit l'émigration une phrase a fait
polémique lorsque le ministre a expliqué
que les migrants compare les
législations des pays pour choisir la
plus avantageuse
on écoute gérard collomb le sénat aime
beaucoup pour pouvoir trouver ses
propres repères
regardez à les différentes législations
pour voir un peu comment nous se situe
par rapport aux autres pays européens
puis je vous dire monsieur le président
qu'il n'ya pas que le sénat qui fait du
benchmarking mais que les migrants aussi
font un peu de benchmarking pour
regarder les législations à travers
l'europe qui sont va dire les plus
fragiles et voyez par exemple que telle
nationalité que là encore je ne je ne
citerai pas elle se dirige plutôt sur
tel pays
non pas parce qu'elle est plus
francophile mais tout simplement parce
qu'elle juge que là c'est plus facile
valérie rabault est ce que les propos de
gérard collomb vous choque
alors il me choque pour deux choses
quand on est ministre de l'intérieur on
ne doit pas c'est un peu méprisant
on doit garder une forme de dignité de
l'état parce qu on incarne la dignité
d'état avec d'autres mais quand on est
ministre de l'intérieur en est forcément
en première ligne sur cette question là
et puis le deuxième volet il dit il ya
des comparaisons il souligne que des
législations différentes ce qui est vrai
mais il est quand même aujourd'hui au
gouvernement un poste très élevé donc il
devrait associer l'ensemble des
ministres de l'intérieur de l'union
européenne le présent macron a fait de
l'europe un sujet crucial pour sa
présidence ils devraient les associés
pour que effectivement on trouve une
solution commune en europe
encore une fois les crises la crise des
réfugiés est une question qui doit être
traité au niveau européen il devrait
aussi demander à faire sauter les
aspects de dublin
si vous êtes arrivés par l'italie que
vous êtes depuis un an en france il faut
que vous retourniez en italie ou en
grèce ou ailleurs ça dépend de dieu vous
êtes arrivé pour aller refaire vos
papiers ça n'a pas de sens
ça n'a pas de sens donc quand on est
ministre de l'intérieur plutôt que de se
complaire dans la petite phrase on
ferait mieux d'agir et d'agir de porter
une démarche européenne
ces propos ont été condamnés y compris
ou embarrassé en tout cas y compris dans
la majorité n'ont pas été formellement
condamnés
est ce que par exemple le premier
ministre devrait le faire premier
ministre de verre devrait rappeler à son
ministre de l'intérieur que il a une
fonction imminente et que par conséquent
il doit incarner cette dignité de l'état
qui ne peut pas se complaire dans des
petites phrases et des attaques qui ne
sont pas digne de la france de ce type
là gérard collomb était l'un des barons
du parti socialiste escale de l'analyse
chez lui aujourd'hui mais je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas je me suis même posé la
question pour la voûte et j'ai du coup
je suis allé revoir lire sa biographie
et j'ai vu qu'il avait été élu la
première fois en 1981
donc il fait vraiment partie de ceux qui
doivent beaucoup de choses au parti
socialiste mais sans doute est il oublié
allez c'est l'heure de retrouver notre
partenaire politique du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et on accueille tristan kinomap
waël merci d'être avec nous cette
semaine tristan bonjour là bonjour vous
êtes membre de la commission des
finances
et on a appris cette semaine que son
président eric woerth était mis en
examen dans le cadre de l enquête qui
est menée sur les comptes de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy peut-il rester à cette
fonction malgré sa mise en examen
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
alors la réponse était oui moi je refuse
je refuse que les députés se
transforment en justiciers quel qu'il
soit il ya une justice qui fait son
travail et par conséquent si vous me
posez la question de savoir si oui il
peut rester je vous réponds oui
joris prudence quand gouvernement quand
un ministre est bien d'accord mais les
jurisprudences si on est pas si on n'est
pas d'accord avec cette idée là le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
est en train de revoir le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale inscrits propose
d'inscrire dans le règlement que des
présidents de commission s'y sont mis en
examen ne peuvent pas rester président
de commission
c'est tout mais si vous me posez c'est
la question savoir si aujourd'hui il
peut rester je vous réponds oui alors il
ya une autre question qui commence déjà
agité un peu la commission des finances
et le budget 2010 9
on parle notamment des aides sociales
dans un contexte on voit que la
croissance augmente
est-ce qu'il faut revoir le niveau des
aides sociales notamment les primes qui
permettent de revenir à l'emploi le
gouvernement a envoyé des signaux
contradictoires vous vous en pensez vous
en pensez quoi
je pense que la prime d'activité est une
très bonne chose il vaut mieux inciter
les français à retrouver un travail
plutôt qu'à rester chez eux et parfois
ils retrouvent des postes qui sont pas
très payer et qui conduirait si les
prenait sans le soutien de la prime
d'activité avoir moins de revenus que
quand il rester chez eux
donc cette la question de la prime
d'activité est une latrine d'activité
est une bonne mesure
d'ailleurs le président de la république
l'avait dit pendant sa campagne
puisqu'il avait dit l'après une activité
est une bonne mesure je vais l'augmenter
de 50 % ça c'était pendant la campagne
c'était il ya un an
vous voulez que je m'en suis un peu ça
sabrina mais là c'est du brouillon de
chez brouillon ensuite pendant la loi de
finances il augmentait de 20 euros est
là aujourd'hui nous dit ah non
dans l'après une activité non non ça va
pas donc vous comprenez bien que les
yoyos permanent où il n'y a pas de cap
et surtout il n'y a pas de décisions qui
soient cadrées encore une fois la
fiscalité c'est la vérité des prix vous
pouvez pas m'en tire dessus parce que
les français s'en rendent parfaitement
compte et là ils se rendent compte que
on est rentré dans une phase assez
brouillonne une question sur le ps
olivier faure a pris ses fonctions il ya
deux mois il c'est le nouveau premier
secrétaire est un peu l'impression qu'il
a du mal parfois à s'installer dans ses
fonctions notamment parce qu'il est gêné
peut-être par françois hollande
est ce que c'est le cas est ce qu'il est
devenu encombrant cet ancien président
socialiste là là franchement je peux pas
vous laisser dire ça j'ai rencontré
l'ancien président de la république
françois hollande à toulouse et j'ai
l'impression qu'on a retrouvé mois le
voilà le personnage que j'ai connus
avant qu'il soit présent la république
qui a une capacité incroyable de
dialogue avec les français alors je
pense que sa fonction de président
attention sa fonction de président de la
république l'a peut-être éloigné mais
sincèrement dans les contacts que j'ai
vu qu'il a nouées qui est en train afin
qu'il est en train de renouer avec les
français
il ya une vraie sympathie partagée des
deux côtés je pense que lui en avait
envie et je pense que les français qui
viennent à sa rencontre
personne ne les force à venir faire
trois heures de queue pour aller faire
signer un livre ont aussi besoin d'avoir
ce contact est aussi c'est cette forme
de sympathie donc oui c'est parfaitement
c est légitime et utile une dernière
question sur le ps sur les européennes
il va y avoir un conseil national le 9
juin prochain pour commencer à discuter
de la stratégie vous avez en tête le
portrait robot de la tête de liste
idéale qui pourrait remettre le ps en
seine je pense que il faut qu'il y ait
une personnalité qui qui incarne leur
part je sais que vous allez me dire ces
bateaux ce que je dis lui c'est un peu
c'est le vrai mais l'europe a été
désincarné l'europe est beaucoup
critiqué mais l'europe est un vrai
projet qui devrait être un projet d'
enthousiasmant que c'est cette force là
qui doit être portée par la tête de
liste moi je considère que françois
mitterrand le faisait parfaitement bien
mais effectivement c'est une génération
qui avait connu la guerre et qui voulait
mettre son enthousiasme pour la dépasser
et voilà donc mais effectivement le
casting est ouvert mais ce sera de la
fin merci beaucoup mais les rivaux
d'avoir été avec nous cette semaine
merci merci merci thibault merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]